♪♪♪♪
-Hey, everybody, welcome
to this week's "Corrections,
where we're going to try
to address some
of the mistakes we made
because our efforts
are always
to get things exactly righ
and, when we don't, we're very
happy to admit we got it wrong
Screwed something up
top of the show.
In "A Closer Look," I referred
to the Afghani city of Kabul
as "Kabool."
I was told
right before I came out,
"Remember it's 'Kobble,'
not 'Kabool.'"
Still said "Kabool."
That one's on me.
"Criminy" was in a sketch
this week, "Closer Look."
I knew it was "crihmihnee.
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker, over there,
tells me it's "crime-ihnee."
[ Laughter ]
Will you cop to that?
-Oh, 100%.
-Yeah.
-I still think it is.
-Okay.
Well, this isn't about that.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, you can see how you get
bullied into something.
And, again,
I had eaten it pretty hard
on "surreptitiously" last week
and Shoemaker had corrected me
so I take his word for it
on criminy.
By the way, I don't know
why I'm listening to him.
Joe Manchin,
who's from West Virginia,
is the guy who said it.
Shoemaker, over there,
is from the South Bronx.
It's not like he's using the
same jargon as West Virginians
[ Laughter ]
Just smoking weed in the '70s,
putting on James Taylor.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Shoemaker ]
Crime-ihnee, man.
[ Laughter ]
Couldn't be farther away
from West Virginia.
The only coal you ever dug
was John Coltrane.
Baze wrote that joke.
[ Laughter ]
I've been told a bunch
that I say "pundit" wrong,
that I say, "pundent."
What else?
[ Laughter ]
Hey, we had a joke
about Lindsey Graham directing
a musical version of "Our Town
in regional theater
and a bunch of people told m
that "Our Town" isn't a musical.
I know that.
I mean, it was a joke.
It's not, obviously, a good one.
But...
[ Laughter ]
would "Our Town" be worse,
if it had a song?
[ Laughter ]
Bill Gates was on the show
and I guess, five or six times
I called him "Phil" Gates.
[ Laughter ]
What else?
You know, I'm also going
to stop anybody
who's watching this
right now online
and they're going to write
their comment's going
to be like,
"Uh, I can't believe
this wasn't on TV."
It's, uh, [bleep] not.
[ Laughter ]
It's only for YouTube.
Just looks like it's on TV
Because we're paying
TV money to make it.
[ Laughter ]
But, all in all, I think,
a pretty good week, right?
[ Laughter ]
So we got criminy, Kabul,
pundit, Bill Gates.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, there we go.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you for your feedback.